It is one of the few elements that is more or less
totally useless.
Protactinium is an element,
which is actually much more interesting than I expected.
The first interesting fact is that it is one of the elements whose
existence was predicted by mental layer.
You've probably all heard how Mendeleev predicted the existence of gallium and
scandium because there were holes in his periodic table and
he also worked out that there was a hole between Thorim and
uranium, where he felt there should be an element. Now,
the reason that people don't make such a fuss about protecting them
in the context of mental live is that protecting them was only really
tied down, discovered properly in 1918. Well,
after the death of men Mendeleev,
whereas he was here to celebrate gallium and scandium,
and that made him famous.
The problem with protecting him is that it exists in a
very, very small quantities in nature.
And it is called protecting him originally.
It was called Pluto actinium because it decays by
radioactivity to form actinium originally
because Mendeley didn't know about the, these series,
the length nights,
and actinides he put protactinium here.
So you would have after actinium you would have rim protecting him and then
uranium.
And so he thought that the chemistry of protecting him would be
similar to that of tantalum.
And it turns out that it is quite similar and that was how it was
isolated.
The chemical problem is that when people were looking
at all Wars,
these are the minerals that contain metals,
the ores of uranium.
There was some radioactivity which suggested that there may be another
element which could decay by emission of an alpha
particle helium nucleus to make actinium.
So it would jump two spaces to the left to make actinium
and the atomic number would go down by two.
The problem was how to isolate this material,
radioactive element from all the other radioactive elements that are
found in minerals with uranium.
And as you probably know that radium and polonium,
we've also been isolated from these minerals.
So there's a real mixture and it was the, um,
Austrian chemist physicist.
Lisa Meitner working in the Institute together with auto
Hahn who eventually in 1918,
found a chemical way of precipitating the
elements of this group. And at the same time,
as she precipitated those,
the ProTech Timonium was also precipitated because its chemistry was similar
and she found some sign of the radioactivity in that
material that should precipitated.
And that was deemed to be the discovery of protecting him.
And it was published in 1918.
They proposed the name pro two actinium everybody find it difficult,
say pro to actinium. So it quickly got contracted to protecting him.
That's very easy to say no,
but it's easier than pro to acting all the elements
above led in the periodic table have a degree of
radioactivity.
So if we had the lump of protecting him here,
it would be extremely dangerous in terms of it's retroactive to Cain,
the isotope that's the particular form of
protecting him.
That was discovered by Lisa Meitner had a half-life
of, I think 32,000 years, a few years earlier,
the chemist Fagans discovered an isotope that had a
half-life of only one and a half minutes, which was so short lived.
He called it the name volume, big firm brief. So it was brilliant.
And so that in a way was the first discovery of protecting
them. But it turns out that there is a custom that if
several different isotopes of an element to discovered whoever discovers the
longest lived isotope wins and they're deemed the
discover,
there are two other parts that aspects I think interesting about protecting
them. The first one is just like mental life said it does
form an oxide, PA two Oh five. In fact,
this is its most staple compound. The second thing,
which is perhaps a more interesting fact for those of you who are real
nerds for the periodic table,
is that it is one of the occasions where the atomic
weight of the element you can see here 231 point something is
lower than the atomic weight of the element before it there's another quite
well-known pair here that potassium at 39 is
slightly lighter than argon, which is the element that precedes it.
So these inverted pairs meant that
unfortunately,
mental life predicted the wrong atomic weight for protactinium
is 231. And he said it's 235,
which is still not a bad guess.
There an attempt to make quite a large amount of it.
Many years ago in the UK,
where 60 tons of material were processed to make
125 grams of protactinium.
And according to this book, the people,
people paid half a million dollars for the, um,
starting material,
but they were only charging $3,000 a gram for what they made.
So if you do quick maths, you can see,
even before you count in the labor,
they made a loss on the material. Why were they making it?
Then I have no idea.
It is used for the dating of
sediments at the bottom of the ocean.
People measure the ratio of the isotopes of protect Tinian and Thorim.
And from the value of this ratio,
they can tell approximately how old the sediment is at the bottom of the sea.
So you can argue whether or not that is really a use.
It is more perhaps an application than the use.